tech giants dominate american markets
microsoft facebook apple amazon and
alphabet
google's parent company account for
almost a quarter of the value of the s
p 500 nearly double their share five
years ago
big tech dominance fuels concerns over
the level of power these companies wield
numerous anti-trust lawsuits have been
brought against tech firms
and there are increasing calls for
greater regulation over them
i can't answer that question yes or no
amy klobuchar a democratic senator from
minnesota
is a vocal campaigner for reform she's
chair of the senate antitrust
subcommittee
when you have monopolies controlling
search engines
and monopolies controlling app stores
you're not going to get those
innovations that would allow you to get
at the true problems that the products
are creating
in an interview with the economist asks
podcast
senator klobuchar discusses whether
america's mega companies
should be broken up amy klobuchar
welcome to the economist asks
well thank you anne it's great to be on
now the word antitrust
it strikes me as a bit of a historical
artifact
it it just it harks back to a time
when big oil rail and steel truss had
their grip
on the american economy is antitrust the
right
concept for what you want to tackle now
in the 21st century
i would actually prefer to call it
competition policy like they do in
europe
but i'm kind of stuck with our words we
have here right now the reason
it's relevant is that we've now reached
our own gilded age
and the players are different and the
companies are more sophisticated they
have names like google
and facebook they are companies that do
things like
increase the price of a simple drug like
insulin
or take a baby's heart drug by the
competitor
corner the market and take the treatment
costs from 80 bucks a treatment
to sixteen hundred dollars i would argue
even more than back then
we need anti-trust enforcement cards on
that monopoly board
we need a check and balance on these
companies for those of us who believe in
capitalism
and believe that we must rejuvenate it
by having more competitors
it's a literal cause that has to be met
or we are going to become another china
uh with
just gatekeeper companies and no choices
for consumers
we've seen corporate concentration rise
during the pandemic but also general
trend
in that direction in in many industries
are you
more concerned ultimately about
technology than you are about
other american industry but is there
something specifically concerning
about technological consolidation i
think the challenge with tech
is that um it is such an animal onto
itself and it has given us these
incredible innovations
and employs so many people and all
that's great none of that really has to
go away
when att was broken up they had given us
a bunch of great things in america and
across the world as well
but that did not stop our government
from saying wait a minute this is a
vertical monopoly they own all the
equipment under it
and it's a horizontal monopoly in terms
of the phone service
and we want to have more options we want
to have more options with cell phones
they broke them up cell phone options
went through the roof
and att itself said they were a stronger
company because they were forced to
compete
that's what we're dealing with right now
so when it comes to tech
you can do this by regulation yes you
can put in place privacy regulations
europe is doing this you can do it with
privacy regulations and limits on
misinformation and limits on immunity
and then you can put in special things
like for app stores we just had a big
hearing on that
um but you could also do it um through
generic antitrust enforcement which i
think is a good way to go
and then finally finally you can unleash
the power of capitalism
how will we ever know if instagram or
whatsapp would have developed the bells
and whistles
to do a better job on privacy or
misinformation
we don't because in mark zuckerberg's
word in an email that was discovered
last year
he literally said these brands are
nascent
but they are meaningful and then in his
words
they could become disruptive to us
and then he bought them if you have a
free market that works then companies
can develop
solutions to problems like
misinformation and privacy
when you have monopolies controlling
search engines and monopolies
controlling app stores
you're not going to get those
innovations that would allow you to get
at the true
problems that the products are creating
so
let's be devil's advocate on that of
course
you're the economist and say
historically governments have intervened
when there was evidence that a huge
company
was causing consumer harm but consumers
do continue to buy
things and huge amounts from amazon from
apple because it's convenient
they use google's services very
willingly
it is the standard for anti-trust
intervention
changes that it could actually hurt
consumers
and with the best will in the world are
you entirely sure where that dividing
line lies and how far you should push it
i'm talking about allowing competitors
to have a chance look what happened in
australia
they google at 90 percent market share
there and and and so
so did uh facebook when australia tried
to charge for content in order
to bolster up news organizations which i
think we should do here as well
then they said well we're taking our
marbles we're going home and good luck
with that because we have 90 percent of
the market share
that is what monopolies do then there
was public pushback microsoft did stand
up and said hey we'll do this
but they were less than ten percent of
the market share they were less than
five percent of the market share um and
so that's not a realistic option right
now and i think we need
realistic options and to get there you
need to put conditions in place
so these monopolies google and apple on
the app stores
aren't allowed to say hey you can't even
say if you can get a cheaper deal on the
website and we're going to by the way
charge you
30 percent of what you bring in but
we're not going to charge some companies
maybe we'll focus more on our
competitors
this is wrong this is why europe
embarked on a year-long investigation of
the app stores
these companies can still offer their
innovative products
but maybe they won't be the only ones
the battle royale on this set between
the maker of fortnite epic games and
apple the world's
most valuable tech firm is due to each
closing argument soon
but legal experts do expect apple to win
and given that expectation how would you
propose raining in tech firms it sounds
not only that
you need to change laws but you will
have a
huge long tale of cases which will be
fought
and in this case may well uh go against
the
anti-trust argument okay well first of
all i don't concede what will happen in
that case after the
hearing that we just had where there was
bipartisan republican democrats
horror at what we learn from spotify
tile
and match.com and so what i would
propose
first of all is that we need to have
stronger enforcement agencies
and that means making sure they're not a
shadow of their former selves which they
are right now even from the ronald
reagan days
senator grassley who's a republican from
iowa and i
uh actually have a bill that would put
more funding into those agencies i think
that's really important you can't take
on
the biggest companies the world has ever
known with duct tape and band-aids
the second thing is that you have to
have the investigations occur so that
the answer may
be simply putting in conditions so that
you're allowed to talk about where you
can get a cheaper deal
so that you don't have to pay thirty
percent and no not all that money is
necessary
for security one of the things that we
hope to learn in the epic games case
is how much money apple is really making
off of their app stores because they
claim they need all that money
for security epic games i think has
projected in one public document
that they think it's like 75
profit turn okay that's pretty high
and so all of that should go into the
thinking of either regulators that look
at it and if they won't
then yeah you could pass a bill that
would put in some constraints
on what's happening with the app stores
to allow for more fairness for those
that are purchasing apps on the app
stores
and once the verdict is reached
whichever way it goes
the question is if you look at the
european commission's remedies i know
you work closely
with the uh european union on this
question
is that not much seems to change and
that actually is in in some sense as
surprising or
disappointing to many in europe if you
look at an example of
alphabet the google parent company which
was fined
multiple times remedies were demanded
indeed imposed by
the commission but in fact the market
share for google
has hardly budged so it would appear to
have been ineffectual
it's the beginning and when you look at
the breakup of att that took
several american presidencies to get
through it
and there hasn't been enough action in
america the only major suits that
happened were at the very end of the
trump administration and by the way i'm
glad they brought those suits and i'm
glad that it's bipartisan
from one administration to another the
major lawsuits against facebook and
google
that's just the beginning so i think
that as americans we should take some
responsibility here
that it's time for us to join with
europe and act and i think that's what
you see finally happening
out of these departments but it's my job
as a member of the senate and a leader
in this area
to say okay we gotta make sure we have
the funding so that they can do
these lawsuits and we need to update our
laws including our privacy laws
in the u.s so i believe some of this is
on us i'd love to know if you think
donald trump should be banned from
twitter and facebooking definitely the
oversight board of facebook has upheld
the platform's decision to ban donald
trump
after those posts he released relating
to the attack on
the capital in january should they be
deciding
who gets de-platformed i think that it
was the right decision and when you have
this enormous power
they are consulting with others and i
think that donald trump is the
disinformer in chief uh when you look
back he is still
you know maybe if he had changed his
tune and said he was wrong
but this is a guy that basically is
still discrediting our democracy
he is lying to people he's telling them
that
he actually won the election he is
casting doubt and as we know from the
insurrection
people were believing that and his
primary and really only
conveyor for those views was social
media platforms
these guys are making huge money the
social platforms
i think that they should be able to
hire the people to do the checking to
get this stuff off of there because it
is greatly influencing people
and that's just not right it's going
people are going to die
because people other people or
themselves are believing stuff like
the vaccines as i heard from a neighbor
the vaccines
put a microchip in your arm a guy that
worked at a cafe right down the block
for me
he said his mother-in-law wasn't getting
the vaccine because of that and she read
it where
she read it on facebook you can listen
to the full
interview in our podcast the economist
asks
every week we talk to a high profile
figure click the link opposite
to find this episode and thanks for
watching
[Music]